breaking news coming from Michigan this
morning this is this is the dramatic
scene right off of Main Street in
downtown Midland Michigan where
catastrophic flooding has inundated the
streets after two dams burst flooding is
out of control in Midland County that's
northwest of Saginaw and the governor
has declared a state of emergency there
she says the city which has a population
of 42,000 could be nine feet underwater
think about that for a second by this
afternoon
Anthony some 10,000 people Gail are
living near the two dams have already
been told to evacuate the river that
runs between the dams and Midland is
about to crest four feet above its old
record Adriana Diaz is following this
fast developing story frightening video
captures the moment the Edenvale dam in
Midland County collapsed it was one of
two catastrophic dam failures in the
area yesterday this is serious and it is
time for people to take action to keep
themselves safe and to evacuate late
Tuesday Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer pleaded with residents to seek
higher ground we are anticipating an
historic high water level the Edenvale
and Sanford dam breaches come as
record-breaking rainfall of more than
seven inches drenched parts of the
Midwest this week causing water to
quickly rise to historic levels the
National Weather Service has issued
emergency flash flood warnings for
communities surrounding the dams
emergency responders went door-to-door
early Tuesday morning before the
breaches to warn residents to get out
I've been here approximately 26 years
and have never had this type of
situation occur
both dams already had questionable track
records in 2018 the Edenvale dam was
given an unsatisfactory condition rating
by the state the Sanford dam received a
fair condition rating meanwhile Michigan
is still fighting to stave off the
spread of coronavirus governor Whitmer
urged residents seeking refuge at
shelters to continue social distancing
and wearing face masks to go through
this in the midst of a global pandemic
is almost unthinkable but we are here
and to the best of our ability we are
going to navigate this together
now this comes as parts of Michigan are
set to reopen as soon as Friday so the
state is dealing with two major
challenges managing those reopening and
assessing the damage from the dam
failures Tony
Adriana thank you very much let's get to
Midland Michigan city manager Brad K he
joins us now
Brad we just heard that parts of your
area could be nine feet underwater by
this afternoon you're there right now
what are you seeing what are you hearing
we're hearing a lot of that exactly we
are live it we live in a river valley in
midland we're used to river floods but
this is something that we've never
experienced before we've already
exceeded the highest record level floods
we ever had and we are looking to
continue probably about another four as
many as eight feet of water coming
through our city within the next few
hours we saw some footage there of first
responders in your area going door to
door asking people to evacuate but those
evacuation orders are not mandatory so
what's your message to people this
morning who may not be heeding the
warning the messages take it seriously
this is an important flood it's a
serious flood it damages property and
will damage property and it's seriously
risks lives we have asked people to
leave we started doing that yesterday
afternoon the sooner that they do that
the better we are still waiting for a
dam to fully fail which we expect
sometime today and when that happens
we'll have as few as three hours before
those flood waters will rise rapidly and
Brad and for people who do want to get
out if they get into their vehicles what
precautions are being taken
what's being setup to help them get out
safely
well there are routes or the important
part a lot of our streets are closed
there simply flooded with water they're
not safe to pass through so people need
to know where they're going and the best
way to do that is to get on to the city
and the county's websites look to see
which roads have been closed in which
way they can get there and then secondly
they need to know where to go our first
preference of course is that they find
either family or friends that they can
lodge with in a place that is safe and
that they'll be able to get to and from
but if they can't reach that or they
don't have those resources in the area
we do have shelters that are open and
available to them with beds that are
available and will be available for as
long as they need them all right that's
good to know and we heard you say
there's another dam that you think might
go by later today but hopefully it holds
mr. K thank you very much and we'll let
you get back to work